[Music]
this episode we want to just start using
more parts of our library and add it to
our game mainly we're going to focus on
items today because our whole little
demo rpg library supports
items buffs all kinds of stuff like that
but until we actually put them in the
game they don't do much so yeah we're
going to focus on items so the first
thing i always do when i record these
episodes is i go over to github see if
there's any pool requests doesn't look
like there's any some people
occasionally like to leave comments
about my design decisions and stuff and
your words mean completely nothing if
you don't go make a pull request just to
have you know that you can rage all you
want but hey this is public you can go
make the changes you want to make
propose them you're just going to leave
comments about it i'm going to be honest
i don't care yeah so right now the
player
fights monsters over and over that's
just a little rpg prototype we have it's
kind of a battle arena it does have a
map so we could do some pretty cool
stuff like we could expand on this map
and we know you know the monster is a
capital m the player is a capital p we
have all that stuff in here and that's
just based on us just setting it to that
so what i think would be kind of fun is
what if the monster started dropping
stuff now we know about our armor slots
so if we go into armor we know we got
these slots one two three four five six
seven eight we got eight different
things and with weapons we got a few
different things there three different
things and what else do we have we have
potions we'll probably just do healing
potions although we do support buffs
we're not going to worry about that
right now but basically what i want to
do is have the monster start dropping
stuff and whatever drops we'll just put
it into the player's inventory and uh
we'll try to
make a little system where the player
can actually go through their inventory
and equip stuff and see their character
sheet now that's an awful lot there's
just no way we're gonna get that all
done in one episode so we're just gonna
get as far as we can and let's just
start with
making the monsters actually drop
something so let's just make a function
called
maybe we'll just call it drop item
all right we'll go void drop item
and what we want to do for this i think
i'm just going to go off the player
level like the higher level you are
maybe the better stuff will drop and the
way we're going to do this is probably
just use create items we need to look at
our public header and what we have
available
there so let's go demo rpg
and just bring in our item header
[Music]
take a quick look at it and see if we
can recall exactly what we're doing here
okay so there's an item and we need to
use
the create item or the item manager i
believe it's called which is
public here so we do have access it but
basically access to it but basically we
want to actually make the items with
item manager so let's just put that in
here as well
and let's just have this drop item
return
and item pointer the same thing
that item manager drops
or uh creates
so this creates items it's got all our
functions that we need to equip and
stuff
and we're just going to use these in our
game we got equip we got used we got
move to backpack probably just going to
use move to backpack mainly
this episode i don't think we're going
to get into deleting but if we need to
update anything in the library we can do
that too to support any of the stuff
we're doing all right so let's go ahead
and do it we need to consider well
basically the player level
so i think it would make sense here to
either pass in the player or you know we
just kind of globally know about the
player since it's just up here declare
it as a global but going forward we
might make it so it's not that way so we
have to basically decide do we want to
keep the player global or do we want to
pass it in
all the time
and really we could do it either way and
we're kind of mixing and matching
mixing and matching matching right now
because right here we're taking in the
player although technically we already
know about it but who knows maybe we
want to go multiplayer in the future and
if there's multiple players then we need
to know which one we're talking about so
in that case we need to pass it in but
also this is a teaching series so i just
want to show things in multiple ways
sometimes and that way you're getting
the broadest knowledge possible rather
than just repeating the same thing over
and over
so this time we're just going to use the
global one i guess but later we can
change this and bring in whatever we're
calculating off of
but for now we're just going to go
well we're going to use random we need
to come up with a system
of dropping things and this is gonna be
a little odd because
we know that from last episode just the
way it's designed the players gonna get
taxed out they're gonna get hit enough
times
that uh they're gonna die with inviting
about three monsters and after fighting
about three monsters there's not a whole
lot they can do
uh they're just gonna lose so monsters
definitely need to be at least dropping
healing potions that you can use
and then weapons and armor and that
should be good enough also another thing
that the library doesn't handle is what
armor and magic resist actually does
like sure it increases your stats but
there's nothing in the damage
calculation that looks at your armor or
anything so that is something we have to
decide on our games in which is intended
because uh yeah you can see what the
armor is and you can see what the damage
is and you can do what you want with it
rather than it having all the
calculations we can balance our game how
we want it just has the ability to get
them or not all right well without
further ado let's get to item drops so
we got some random stuff let's think
about this we got how many different
pieces of armor did i say
one two three four five six seven eight
pieces of armor
two different weapon types
so that's ten different items and then
potion which we're probably just gonna
do healing potion for now so there are
11 different things that could in theory
drop at least for now to get started
so eight armor items two weapon types
you know melee in range and one potion
so
11 different
rock types and basically we can do this
however we want but we want to randomize
it so we want to somehow randomize
which of these drop and we can weight
them as we want so the first thing we're
going to do is grab a random number and
then we're probably just going to switch
on that number and grab something based
on the player's level for whatever we
randomly rolled i don't know if i said
that in a way that makes a whole lot of
sense but we're just going to program it
up and go for it
drop seed is going to be
n2k random well we got to go random
again and we can give this maybe we give
it 1 through 100 that should be fine to
start
and that'll just get us a random number
between 1 and 100 and we can just go
switch on drop seed and then we just
need 11 different cases well i guess
we're going to have to do an if else a
switch is going to be a little too
difficult i was trying to think of a way
to give it like fall throughs and stuff
like that but there's really no great
way so we'll just say if drop seed is
less than
five
but like a five percent chance of
whatever this first thing is we'll maybe
give them the first piece of armor
and we can we can just go on and on like
that basically
i'll say a drop seed so let's just kind
of get this structured out
and the way that if else works is going
to make this kind of easy to scale along
and delete that one actually because we
just keep going up by five and say less
than five because the way if else works
is when you've got a big thing of if
else's it checks the first one if that
succeeds it goes into that one it
doesn't do any of the other ones this
one fails it goes to the next one
so we don't have to do like a less than
greater than check we can make it
somewhat efficient by doing this and
we're just going to keep copying this
down for a while see 5 10 15 20 25 30 35
40 45 50 55. we need 11 basically one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven okay so there's 11 of them
and we need to
kind of figure out this percent a little
better uh let's go with these for the
start
so we'll just make it five percent
increments see what you get
and the last chunk is just going to be
potions so there's going to be like a 45
chance of getting a potion and somewhere
around a percent chance of getting
anything else now we could weight this a
little more with like you know counting
by six or something
okay there we go there's a nice little
chart
and i think what we want to do here is
just gonna
we're just gonna make the return item
here maybe maybe even at the top top or
maybe you know maybe we want a chance
that it just drops nothing so let's
let's go ahead and program that in here
too so just the last case here
and let's kind of pseudo code this out a
little bit while we're at it and we need
to see this armor we need all these so
let's go ahead and just
put these
somewhere for us to look at as we go
i think we remember the weapon types
there's only two the armor one's a
little harder to remember everything
about it and basically what we want to
do here
is we want to return the item return
create item and that is in item manager
we just do it directly like this even
create
armor
and we give it a name and we got to do
something about giving these
names but we could just go we could even
just say helmet for now until we'll come
up with a system for giving them stats
in a little bit but for now let's just
get the core of this ready and then
we'll worry about
scaling it with the player level for now
let's actually get something now i feel
like if it's armor
you've got to at least have one armor
let's just do one armor for now on any
particular slot
and the slot is armor slot helmet or
head
there we go
so that's going to return a created
armor with those stats and we can use
this power of random later to help make
these a little more versatile but for
now let's go ahead and just copy this
down and
just continue on let's make a chest slot
and let's just call this like
breastplate
and we'll just continue what our leg
piece called i can't remember
found this interesting site medieval
collectibles
so maybe let's just have a gander here
and see what they call it i don't know
anything about this site but apparently
you can order
armor and stuff off of it
kind of cool tassets
never heard of tassets but i guess it's
what they're called or at least little
side things
that like hang from your belt or
whatever
okay we'll just call it
tasset okay i don't know if that's
technically accurate or not oh there's
also greaves as i guess there's greaves
ah this is like the shin guard type
armor we don't really have all that
programmed and then
functional leg armor here well what am i
getting into
yeah this is what i'm looking for just
leg guards okay let's just stick with
leg guards apparently there's multiple
pieces so we could get like real
technical
and put all those pieces in here but
that's a little bit much
we're just going to keep it simple here
as simple as possible at least i'm only
going to look it up if i have no idea
what they're called
like hands we can just call gloves and
of course we want like you know an
actual
proper random chart at some point but
we're just hacking it for now
oh the ring slots are interesting
because
we got to think about how this works
rings should fit in either slot so we
don't necessarily need to say it's a
ring one or a ring too i didn't really
think about that actually but
whatever let's let's stick with it
so that's something that needs corrected
is we need
there to be two ring slots but we need
rings to equip on either slot and that
doesn't really work that way right now
so we're not really going to worry about
it because basically if we call our quip
method on a ring
it's going to go to whatever slot it
says it is it's not going to actually
allow us to use either slot of ring so
maybe we'll fix that at some point but
that might be
[Music]
yeah that might take a little longer
than i would think i guess that's what
i'm getting at
let's call this neck guard so any armor
piece you get at least gives you one
armor i guess that's nice maybe we'll
have the rings do something else
like give you one to all stats or
something
sure let's actually do that i like that
and the neck guard maybe gives you one
armor
or one
resist and one armor sure why not just
vary it up a little bit all right and
now we need some weapons here so let's
do this again except this time create
weapon
and we need a melee weapon here i guess
we need to decide if it's one or
two-handed
we'll just call it like a
one-handed sword sword for now and
doesn't need stats but it does need some
damage and whether it's two-handed or
not so
we'll just say one well maybe let's go
two to three damage
we'll have a scale up later and is this
everything we need okay this needs to be
weapon slot need to spell create
correctly
and there we go and let's go ahead and
make a ranged one and we'll just call it
a bow and it'll do the same damage and
uh we don't want it to have any stats we
just wanted to do some damage stats on
weapons is more for like magical or
special stuff and this one we want to be
a potion so let's go ahead and make a
healing potion once again in case
someone's confused
this here is not part of the library
we're just making a demo implementation
so really it's up to whoever's making
the thing to get as creative as they
want with their implementation
so i'm just winging it to get it a thing
going so for your implementation you can
do whatever you want you don't have to
follow what i'm doing you can change
things up if you think it's better make
a pull request maybe i'll accept it i
probably will if it is actually better
all right i need to look at this
function create weapon is now create
potion and how much does it heal for uh
we need to come up with a random here
let's just randomness let's say it heals
for between two and five
and the item count let's say you get one
or two so maybe you can grab two if
you're lucky one or
two and does it have a buff or not we're
gonna leave this null actually we just
leave it blank
there we go now we get one to two
killing potions
uh somewhere around forty percent of the
time and a lot of chances of dropping
some armor and weapons and this one here
is going to be null pointer so there's
also about a 10 chance you just don't
get anything and if we want multiple
things dropped from a creature or
monster or chest or whatever we can just
call this multiple times and get
multiple items
maybe we'll call this
random drop
or drop random item
i like that
okay so we can we can sort these out and
tweak them as necessary later and we can
do some more randomization in any of
these to give them different stats just
maybe append plus one to the name you do
a lot of stuff like that
i would like to do maybe an example of
one of them just to show you like the
helmet for example we could go
string name and then we could go
we could do a random here uh is magical
we do like an it oh i think i'll do this
yeah we let's do magical power here
and let's call random again and let's go
from zero to two all right and then we
can go
well we want to append whatever this is
and on to the name so we could say like
a plus one and we could use string
stream for this but that's going to get
a little it's gonna get a little gaboo
so maybe we will not worry about that a
whole lot i'm trying to just think of
the simplest way to do it quickly now
let's just do a quick switch statement
it's ugly
it's probably better to use string
stream
but i'm just trying to hack it so case
zero
we can say name equals
just helm you probably see where i'm
going with this eventually we're going
to put name here
hope we need a break
ace one say name equals
plus one helmet so bonus points to you
if uh you go on the github onto this
repo
and make this work with string stream
and expand this at all
default here
that's nothing but break okay so now we
got a little very name here depending on
how strong it is and we can also vary
these stats a little bit too but we
could just make a stats item that goes
along with this so we go for stats
i don't know we'll just call it local
stats and we could just append that
right in here
just like cell so there's the plain one
let's do the magical one and just make
it all ones i guess
we'd look like this
make a little more armor there we go
magical one does a bit more
and you probably see where this is going
to
and then we're just going to put local
stats down here
and there we have a extremely hacked
system to potentially get magic helmets
now you could do this for all of them or
come up with a system where it does it
a little more in advance so we don't
have to repeat this code over and over
i'll leave that up to someone else
but there is an example of how you could
do it
with this particular system anytime they
roll a helmet it might be magical but
anything else right now not going to be
so magical okay so that function is
pretty well done i think we can just
call it when we need to so let's move on
to the next section defeating a monster
and dropping the item so let's go to the
fight where is the fight
or battle i forget what i called it
enter fight sequence is apparently what
i called it wait i have it in here twice
i'm a little confused apparently i
pasted something in here at some point
okay let's just take this function we
wrote i gotta get this corrected cut it
and i'm just gonna pull up a little
temporary notepad here and paste it over
there
and uh what the heck is going on here
it looks like i might have copied this
whole file down at one point yeah i
don't know i guess i did
let's put our function back in there
could move these functions to the header
if we want
to this pca header but let's just
collapse these for now
so that we can look around a little
better
and let's check out this fight sequence
here it says return is true on when
false otherwise but currently we have
void so we know that's not true we can
just get rid of that
i think what we want to do here is just
right here if they won we'll just get an
item drop
so let's just do that like right here
let's create a drop and tell them what
it was maybe we'll do this notification
part
at the bottom like right here
okay so let's create an item
item drop now we need to make it an item
star and we need to make it equal
drop random item
and that should take care of it it'll
call that function it'll grab something
random we can check if it's null or not
and
we basically if this item is not null we
want to add it to our inventory so let's
separate this out a little bit
these the order of these doesn't matter
a whole lot i'm just trying to think
where we want to do this notification
i guess we'll just do the logic right
after the item drop
so we'll say if item drop
if it actually exists
i guess we yeah let's do it down here we
actually want to say what it is item
let's go item received
because we're going to end up just
putting this in the inventory
now it's only going to do this if this
is not null of course
and we'll just go item drop dot
get data dot name basically they all
have name so it's definitely going to
have a name we don't need to cast it to
anything
so now if it actually drops an item
we'll get to get that but we do need to
add it to our inventory that's kind of
important so we can do that
i guess we'll do in the same check i was
trying to separate them out a little bit
but i don't want to do this if item drop
twice so we're already checking right
here we might as well put it in your
inventory right here as well
and we got to just think about how to do
that
we want a new line at the end of this
too in our
standard now it actually might be better
to make a custom function for this that
takes in the text and formats it how we
want but we're just kind of doing it on
the fly here
so we want to call item
manager
add to backpack or so what was i forget
what it's called let's take a look here
move to backpack and it'll be
item
the item drop and we need to pass in the
player character and that is going to be
layer one dot us
and we might have to do something
specific with this that's just what we
called in our struct
now once a pointer to it so we need to
use the reference
to make it a pointer to it
and the item drop is already a pointer
so once we move it to the backpack the
item is going to be managed by the
backpack that is the idea here
and then we'll have to write a little
further system to call equip from the
backpack or we will worry about that
shortly let's just clean this up get rid
of all these lines that we
can and maybe we'll just write
and a few comments here drop a random
item
we'll do that at the bottom right before
we actually check
let's we'll mess with the order a little
bit first of all we know
they won versus the monster
uh they're gonna gain some xp they're
gonna defeat
yeah we can do this monsters defeated at
the end here gain xp
drop a random item update
uh monsters and create
well i'm trying to think what comma to
put here
notes monsters
it down and prepare
the next one
and there we go
so that is pretty much everything we
need to do
and maybe we'll just go ahead and fight
a few real quick and make sure this item
drop actually works we basically should
have a pretty high chance of getting
something so let's go ahead and run this
and make sure we actually get something
okay let's go ahead and make us a cleric
this time
and we'll move
down to the monster and fight him attack
attack attack looks like the cleric is
doing zero damage
that's kind of a problem
let's run this again so maybe we got a
bug there with our cleric let's go for
warrior this time
and let's attack okay the warrior
appears to be doing some damage item
received press play that's the main
thing we wanted to check okay well we
ran into something else we're gonna
hotfix the cleric was definitely not
doing any damage so let's have a look at
our cleric and maybe figure out why
cleric why why you no do damage
maybe his strength is too low this looks
okay let's take a look at the difference
between warrior not much difference
other than higher strength let's take a
look at our attack method
uh where do we have that exactly do we
have in the classes no we probably have
this in the player character
let's just see if we can find attack
there we go melee attack all right so
let's look at melee attack
it must be this get total strength
divided by four it must be
zero in some cases
like when your strength is less than
three this is becoming a fraction and
this is probably just rounding it to
zero so maybe we'll just do a quick
if the
damage done is less than one then we'll
just make it one it's going to be the
minimum that should fix that
we probably want to do the same thing
with the ranged attack there we go
another thing we could do to fix it is
we could just start it at one but that's
going to make everybody do one more
damage all the time so i like this
method better okay let's just do that
that's fine
there's other ways you could write this
so
you know we can do it as a ternary
operator right here at the end and save
some lines of code and we're not going
to worry about it
let's continue on with what we got let's
try the cleric again
and just make sure we actually do some
battle
yeah we're doing some damage
and we got ring two okay that's
something very good
but now
oh or against the wall there monsters up
here as you can see it's it's working oh
we got a potion of healing but we need a
way to actually do stuff with the items
there we go we lost we defeated two with
the cleric not bad
okay so the dropping of the items does
work correctly let's see if we can make
a little system that just displays our
inventory and we can make a little
hotkey
to press to go to our inventory maybe
like i or something because right now
let's take a look where is that
where our lines of code okay i'm in the
wrong
function i need to go to our main
somewhere in here
we have okay it's right here we have all
our selection type stuff
and here we go we have move
or inventory maybe we'll just put
inventory i
to let them know they have that option
as well and we'll just put another
switch case in here or case i
and in this case we'll just open the
inventory so we just need a function to
do that we'll just call open inventory
so we just need to design this little
function here
and we can do it the same way we you
know we know about the player we
probably want to pass in a player but
maybe we'll call this okay it's called
open inventory we have an enter fight
sequence because essentially we're kind
of going to different screens like we
have you know the map you walk around on
we have this fight sequence we have an
inventory it's not very well defined
how we're naming them and stuff but
we're just hacking it so that's fine i'm
gonna leave it open inventory i was
considering
making it like enter inventory
screen or something so we could sort
that out a little more i'm going to fix
this fight sequence to make it like our
other functions with underscores at
least
but for now all we want to do is just
basically show all the items in the
inventory so we'll do a clear screen at
the beginning of this
and we will just display all the items
let's start with that oh really what i
want to do is i want
you to be able to press hotkeys while
you're in this inventory and look
through it or at least move your cursor
and select through it and maybe if you
hit enter on an item it'll use it or
equip it depending on what it is
so that's quite doable it's just going
to take some working out of the system
so let's get that going here first thing
we need to do is we actually need to get
the backpack
inventory items so let's just do that
with auto because we have
um
a function to do that
so we'll go main character
us because that's the one from the
library
and then we just want to do get backpack
list and that should return all the
items and then we can just do a for loop
here or auto
actually let's do let's make it const by
reference so it's fast now this list of
items
we know is a copy because if we go look
at this it returns backpack
but this backpack is just a list of
pointers and its cons so we can't
actually do anything with it but we're
at least going to be able to look at it
for now we'll figure out how to actually
do stuff with it here shortly basically
all we would need to do is
get that item pointer and use a quip and
that kind of will take care of it we've
got we got to make sure it actually
comes out of the inventory when we equip
so we might have to update the
the back end or the library a little bit
to manage that better because now we're
getting into a real case where we're
actually using it a little more and we
want to like make sure it equips and
de-equips and uses and all that
correctly without leaking memory or
making copies or any weird stuff like
that because right now it's uh
it's not really game tested not battle
tested yet well let's just start out
with displaying it because that's at
least something
well we'll just call this item
lowercase and we will get data
dot name and now what we could do
yeah we probably want to get the total
number of items and make a just a nice
little list and have a little selector
down the side whichever one's selected
we'll put like a
x or maybe a
little hash like this in front of it or
something for the one you have selected
so we'll have to work that out a little
bit
and it's going to get kind of
complicated but we'll see how much we
can get done here just leave it like
this for now for all of them
and just a new line here at the end of
every after every name and that should
be enough let's go ahead and just run
this we need a way to exit the inventory
or maybe we just
press enter
so we're going to do our tried and true
method of
get care here
and we're basically going to say press
enter to continue
which will promptly leave function go
back to the map but at least we can look
at our items so this will just stop it
at the end or it should as long as we
don't have a bunch of things buffered
all right let's go ahead and make a
rogue let's press i nothing happens and
it leaves immediately now the problem
with it leaving immediately is well
there's a new line already
in the buffer from where we hit enter to
get into this so we just need to do
cn.ignore
and uh yeah you can do more than 100
usually people do like integer max or
something but we just want to eat that
new line so that it doesn't
immediately exit let's try this again
and also real quick i noticed there was
an issue with drop random item or said
not all paths return something so
it thinks that it could go off this seed
uh to the bottom here but it actually
can't it's actually impossible because
well
the seeds one to 100 there's no way it's
getting past this but just for the sake
of static analysis stopping the
complaints we could do this
all right
don't make a return here just actually
we could just leave it off entirely at
this point no need to do that final
check and just return no pointer if it's
you know greater than 91.
i also realize this is reverse where
like lower is better which might
make some people complain but it's in
theory the same type of odds anyway it
doesn't really matter
it's just a matter of semantics and how
it's worded all right let's take a look
here let's make a rogue go to inventory
there's nothing in the inventory
that's as expected let's just fix it up
a little bit and just put something at
the top here like
inventory
or current
and then a couple new lines or you know
what actually maybe let's just do this
a couple new lines there
there we go that will at least display
it
and we can clean this up a little bit by
just doing that that looks a little
nicer i think
okay
let's go to our inventory
see there's nothing all right so let's
go fight this monster and see if he
drops something he's whooping our butt
right now dropped a potion of healing
excellent let's make sure that's in our
inventory by checking the inventory
and there we go we got potion of healing
now this
15904 i don't know what's up with that
but basically it doesn't seem to
understand this carrot that we put in
the stream
so let's just go back up here okay it's
this right here yeah this should be
double quotes who knows what that's
actually
doing if it's not double quotes make a
warrior this time because he's got the
most hit points and strength portion of
healing very good let's go into our
inventory
and there it is let's see if we can
defeat a couple monsters and get a few
items helmet very nice
check our inventory there's that helmet
can we defeat one more if we could use
our potion of healing we probably could
but no he got us
okay well we got this far
so next episode we're going to work out
how to equip these items and how to use
potions and
well i mean this uh basically this is
just to give you an idea of how to
extrapolate all this stuff because you
know in theory you don't have to make a
battle arena you can make this a thing
where you go talk to people and they
give you quests and you go do stuff and
then stuff drops and all that stuff i'm
just making a battle arena cause
it's a kind of a nice way to get all the
systems going as quickly as possible but
you can see now
at least from this example where you
should be able to see how you could very
easily make a text based rpg just based
on this type of stuff
and make it do as you want so if you
really want to exercise your skills that
would be the next step is to take this
library and make your own little text
based game off of it or it doesn't
necessarily have to be text based if you
put if you attach some sort of rendering
system to it
you could actually you know move stuff
around and still use these functions to
manage all the behind the scenes stuff
but that would just require you to add
that rendering library or design your
own and that's a whole nother ball game
but that's gonna be it for this episode
hope you enjoyed and we'll see you next
time peace out
[Music]
you